when I came to America but I couldn't
speak English barely speaking any
English and they were playing football
and my friend Eric Godfrey's like he
says you're a Jets fan and so I went
home and I was like I'm a Jets fan it
was my first kind it was my first
American thing so they all had Jets
jerseys we would play and I wanted a
Jets Jersey we were poor we couldn't
afford stuff like that it's not what
immigrants do you know go out and buy 30
Jets Jersey so my mom knitted me one she
made it and the back of this it has my
favorite number number five and says
Gary and I literally wore it every day
and it's my prized possession it's
literally my prized possession
New York Jets is what I do I want to put
in front of the stadium because I still
have it the sweater that my mom knitted
for me and I wanted to say from not
being able to afford a Jersey to buying
the entire [__]
team
[Music]